dans deux semaines maintenant l'europe
passera de 15 à 25 pays membres chaque
jour dans ce journal nous vous
présentons donc les nouveaux arrivants
l'europe va donc passer de 380 millions
d'habitants à 450 le plus petit état ce
sera l'île de malte à l'histoire
tourmentée ce territoire situé au beau
milieu de la méditerranée a subi de
nombreux brassage de civilisation arabe
une installation ensuite des chevaliers
de l'ordre de malte la colonisation
britannique aujourd'hui malte
indépendant vit essentiellement du
tourisme
reportage christelle bertrand ida
raviver les couleurs pour attirer l'oeil
des touristes tous les ans à la même
époque sam prépare la haute 6 jusqu'au
mois d'octobre il va balader sur son
bateau des milliers de vacanciers pour
lui entrer dans l'europe signifie déjà
une baisse de chiffre d'affaires avant
je transportait 48 passagers avec les
normes européennes je ne peux plus en
prendre que 22 ont souffrons beaucoup
tout a augmenté les assurances les
permis de transport et les taxes le
touriste c'est la première source de
revenus des maltais
chaque année près d'un million et demi
de personnes visitent l'île qui va
devenir le plus petit pays d'europe
malte en veut encore plus
lille se rêve destination à la mode
alors on construit en hauteur à tour de
bras
hôtel de luxe appartements au casino
bref ces deals en chantier pour les
hôtels bas de gamme
le tableau se ternit déjà
les tours opérators tire les prix vers
le bas il orchestre une concurrence
féroce
les hôteliers eux ont du mal à s'y
retrouver dans un sens c'est bon pour
nous même si chaque touriste dépense
seulement deux ou trois livres par jour
tu es c'est très peu mais au moins le
talent et plein avec 1 100 personnes
on survit elle a donné du travail à tout
le monde voilà cependant le boss
nous sommes hors saison lille c'est
chaud doucement aux premiers rayons du
printemps
ici les manières du nord et les
traditions du sud se mélangent depuis
des siècles un temps musulmane puis
occupé par les très chrétien chevaliers
de l'ordre de malte
il passe ensuite aux mains des anglais
en héritage les maltais ont gardé la
langue britanniques et quelques objets
du quotidien bien british
pas étonnant alors que plus d'un
touriste sur trois soit anglais ces
menaces est vrai c'est un peu pareil que
chez nous je suis allé dans beaucoup de
pays je voyage surtout pour la culture
la nourriture coeur et pour rencontrer
des gens et fo le patron de l'office du
tourisme gère un des plus gros budgets
de ligue entrer dans l'europe va générer
des subventions supplémentaires déjà
tout attribut qu'une partie des fonds va
servir à moderniser les routes
on a bien besoin une autre partie de
l'argent valait aussi touristique
c'est également très important pour nous
de pouvoir développer l'ensemble de nos
produits
calme un brin désuet typique est coloré
c'est aussi le visage de maths au sud de
l'île les pêcheurs sont encore plus
nombreux que les touristes
il ne reste plus beaucoup d'endroits
comme celui-ci charmant 100 hôtels ni
casino
pour l'instant la zone est protégé mais
le périmètre se restreint les complexes
industriels gagnent irrémédiablement du
terrain